let's bring in Jeff Passan ESPN baseball
insider I'm going to be positive today
Jeff I'm gonna say only nice things
about baseball can you make the same
guarantee I'm trying to be positive
right now because after three months of
reporting on something that absolutely
did not need to happen there's a
schedule that set there player saying
that they're going to go to spring
training on July 1st and everything is
rainbows and sprinkles so I would love
to believe that but there's this there's
this whole code thing too and it scares
me that we've gotten to this point now
and that all of it can be blown up like
that we call you the debunker here
whenever you whenever there's news
myself in the dentists we call you the D
bunker because it's usually like hey
this news came out what did pass and say
oh he debunked it so congratulations
you're the debunker i mike sock and
brock you order a great radio host up at
seattle and they have a theme song for
me every time i come on it's a little
jingle and it goes Jeff Passan
the wet blanket okay I am fascinated by
first base when the players come back if
I get the first base and there's a first
baseman there it's like me with a date
in high school I got the first base so I
got to first base now what is the social
distancing going how do they enforce
that if I want to if I don't want to
take it too far of a lead on I don't and
and that is the you know there's that
there is the catcher and the batter like
there are places on the baseball field
where people are just going to be close
to one another and that is a reality
with which the sport has to deal
baseball in terms of team sports is
probably the friendliest in terms of
just natural social distancing
but there are absolutely elements tag
plays you know yeah he's going in
stealing second somebody is going to be
running over there and is going to be
kicking up dirt and is gonna take his
glove of and it's gonna swipe it
wherever that player is it may be a
glove into which he caught hitting
someone's face that's just the reality
of the situation Dan and if you're going
to bring back baseball you have to live
with these I wouldn't turn them small
risks I don't think that being outside
in most stadiums in standing within a
couple of feet of a player is going to
necessarily pass an infection back and
forth and you know you could have a
first base situation where you just have
a guy playing off a little bit more you
know playing behind the back or playing
in in bunt situations or you know trying
to have the infield in like there are
scenarios where the guys are not going
to be close to each other there are also
scenarios where the guys are going to be
close one all right it's been so long
since we've actually talked baseball
because it's been you know back and
forth volleying these financial terms
here but now that that's sort of settled
for a little while here explain what the
divisions or are going to look at and
then let's actually start handicapping
I'm positive here I'm being positive
let's start handicapping the teams to
beat you know once we start to play I
was gonna say did you see your old
partner on the big show giving the
percentage chance of the World Series
happening this year at a big fat zero Oh
Berman says there's no World Series this
year not yeah get out wet blanket you
anyway Overman is on the Mount Rushmore
of wet blankets so okay let's just 60
games 40 of them are going to be against
divisional opponents while the schedule
is not out yet I believe it's going to
be at one four game series and a pair of
three game series could also be two five
game series just to cut down on travel I
don't think that's the case though there
are also 20 interleague games against
teams
in your geographical area meaning the NL
East is playing the AL East central play
in the Central West playing the West at
the end of that whoever is in first
place and goes to the playoffs you have
two wild-card teams because there are no
expanded playoffs the same format as
last year and at that point I have no
idea if they're going to go to a bubble
for the playoffs if they're going to be
potentially traveling cross-country like
there are a lot of those elements that I
think still are to be determined you
know I thought all along we were gonna
have expanded playoffs here and then
hide out that would have been even
better with you know this frenetic
finish that we're gonna have with 60
games and then the number of teams and
you get into the playoffs and all right
so the team's given you know the
divisions and the matchups here Jeff
give me one or two favorites and one
team that you think will be as maybe a
little bit of a surprise or spoiler
Dodgers are definitely the favorite I
think in all of baseball this year I'm
glad we're going to get to see Mookie
Betts play in a Dodgers uniform because
cuz that would have been truly the most
catastrophic trade in recent memory if
they had given up Alex for Devon Jeter
downs and not gotten a single game out
of Mookie Betts in the American League
the New York Yankees are favorites and
the fact that James Paxton is back and
healthy the fact that Aaron judge is
seemingly healthy Aaron Hicks they're
going to be getting back as well like
they look like they're going to be full
Deathstar operating and who would be
found probably terms of a support you
know I love the San Diego Padres
individual talent and I think Fernando
Tati's jr. is an absolute superstar I
think Chris Patek is going to take the
leap this year and the thing that the
Padres have is the ability to go down
into their farm system and maybe bring
up guys who they wouldn't have in a
normal year when you have a short
schedule like this anything can happen
and a bad losing streak is the sort of
thing that can wipe you off the map
terms of the playoffs whereas an eight
nine ten game winning streak is
sometimes may be all you need you push
you toward that so a guy like McKenzie
Gore who's probably the best pitching
prospect in baseball and who may not
have come up this year is going to get a
chance and if he's up there in a
rotation with paddock with denílson
lament the you know Garrett Richards is
back like they have some arms there and
they have the talent I think not to be a
threat to the Dodgers necessarily but to
certainly play in that wild-card field
the damage have a question you who wants
to do the honors here point Jeff Passan
is on zoom' and Jeff has this lovely
office behind him like most people on
Zoom that we do interviews with they
have office with their awards and a
memorabilia and so forth and a bookshelf
are those fake books behind Jeff Passan
wouldn't you like to know
I think top shelf is phony can I show
you guys something
here we go soon fake fake pitch drop
hold on hold on let me say this fake but
not so thick that you didn't recognize
it immediately you thought no it's
awesome and the people at ESPN have done
a phenomenal job with it however I will
say this there will be a real backdrop
coming in in the near future it's
actually on the obviously at breaking
news right it's on the opposite side of
the office right now what are you
waiting for you've been in quarantine
for four three months you got a
performance-enhancing backdrop here I'm
waiting for the records that I have
ordered to come in because I don't lose
the rage against the machine in the
wu-tang clan and Weezer and Pink Floyd I
don't want to lose that in the backdrop
so I have actual vinyl albums being
shipped to me right now we got to stay
on this story this is this is explosive
Bob Nightingale just called you
fraud I don't know how to respond to
that Peter Gammons is laughing at you
not with okay with that okay nightingale
you got a problem with I will say the
hair looks great and that's real that is
real so we I'm guilty of that as well
once again stay positive Jeff don't be
don't be a debunker here I listen I bunk
when I need to debunk and I'm positive
what I need to be positive in this is a
positive this is a positive thing right
now you guys give the Dennett's credit
you guys scoped out the fake backdrop
called me out on it and as always I'm
telling you what's real and what's not
thank you Jeff that's Jeff the debunker
has it